what up yo i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it is
january 27th in the year 2022 we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv do me a favor if you do
anything subscribe to rumble today
that's really what i'm pushing today
because we're going to get to some big
stories about censorship youtube has
just booted my friend dan bongino
officially he is no longer on youtube
that's it he is exclusively on rumble i
suspect that means that my days here on
youtube may be limited
so if you are watching on youtube i want
you to watch wherever you want to watch
wherever you feel comfortable watching
uh but please subscribe to our rumble
channel because who knows what's what uh
we got a great show for you today i'm
very excited to be back in studio
yesterday was a pre-tape that we had
done the day before because i spent the
day at the offices the new offices of
rumble in sarasota we are building out
some awesome awesome stuff for rumble
and locals and studios and just it's
just great that's on the other coast of
florida so i drove across alligator
alley alligators were chasing me there's
wild panthers there's a florida state
penitentiary i survived i'm back it's
all good so we got some big stories
about uh big tech censorship this crazy
woman nancy pelosi she's running for
re-election and we've got uh if you
didn't see it yesterday i mean her
campaign video or her announcement video
is just completely ridiculous and then
over there in virginia glenn younkin who
fortunately won
uh as governor of virginia cnn is not
happy with him because he's for things
like school choice and not having the
state indoctrinate your children before
i get to any of that though just two
quick things just going on here i woke
up this morning in a very
florida style because there was a lizard
in our bedroom
just next to the bed there was a lizard
right there that is a very florida type
thing that can happen and i was very
excited i was like oh there's a lizard
here i don't know how it got in but how
cool fun lizard
and then after a few minutes i
realized that the lizard was barely
breathing and it was missing a leg it
appears that clyde
brought the lizard in
ate the leg put the mostly dying lizard
on the cold tile i then picked up the
lizard with a
sheet of paper put the lizard outside
i'll check in on the lizard later and
for more on the lizard join us at
rubinreport.locals.com
and then one other thing we have a whole
bunch of people obviously working here
right now helping us fix internet and
there's we're fixing some structural
stuff at the house and building out the
studio and we're painting and all kinds
of stuff so we got a billion roughly a
billion i think that was the exact
number uh people downstairs doing some
stuff right now but this morning a guy
came in to help us out with some some
window stuff and some privacy stuff that
we're doing and i opened the door and
big smile on his face oh man you're dave
rubin i can't believe it how you doing
watch you all the time love the show
watch
and going on and on and on and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say his name unless
i'll i'll ask him maybe later he wants
some promo on his business which i'd be
happy to do but then started telling me
his life story uh his name is carlos and
he runs a company here that he started
out of his truck when he was 18 years
old
he's had the company for 40 years
successful family-run business and he
was just going on and on
he's mexican he was going on and on
about what america is all about how
people don't get it they don't
understand what they're fleeing and all
how backwards everything is and it was
just so refreshing it was so refreshing
which is just so consistent with
everything that i've experienced in this
last you know month and a half roughly
of just so many happy joyous people and
that know what's right about this place
and that is why i'm here to keep florida
florida all right we're going to get to
all the stories but i do have a new
advertiser and i've even got a bottle
here can you believe it
if the last two years have taught us
anything it's that you have to take
control of your health you think
it's clear that you can't simply rely on
the government or big pharma to protect
you and your family that's where z stack
comes in z stack is a specially
formulated immune boosting supplement
that includes zinc quiceratin vitamin c
and vitamin d formulated by dr vlad
zelenko who i'm sure you guys have heard
about we've talked about him on the show
the world renowned doctor that president
trump credited with his successful early
treatment protocol and his decision
decision to
take hcq zstack has been specifically
formulated is kosher and gmp certified
and is produced right here in the good
old u.s of a i just started taking it a
couple days ago i'm feeling pretty good
i have to tell you that might be the
florida sunshine too now more than ever
you have to take control of your health
and your family's health the stack is
formulated to help combat any and all
variants as well as the flu stay ahead
of any potential future variants by
preparing your immune system go to
zstacklife.com
dave and enter the promo code dave to
get a small discount off your first
order that's zstacklife.com
dave promo code dave and now back to me
okay so the first segment of the show in
our first probably
15 minutes here we go we got to do some
censorship stuff there is a massive move
you know there are times when you can
really feel sort of the system the
machine the mainstream thing really
making a push to silence people really
making a push to shadow man people boot
people suspend people whatever term you
want to use and the last couple days
there's really been an uptick in that so
the first part of this is sort of half
good news little bit of half good news
as you know there's been a real assault
on joe rogan lately you know he's had a
bunch of doctors on talking about
you know different treatments that you
could use to possibly
deal with covid and talking to your own
doctor and all that the big one of
course was the viral
interview that he did with dr robert
malone who was one of the mrna
founders one of the originators of the
technology in the first place that's
where this phrase mass formation
psychosis really popped up that we've
all been talking about well any event
musician neil young
has not been happy that joe rogan is on
spotify and neil young is also on
spotify we've got a quote here from fox
news spotify has noticeably kept mum
amid news that neil young reportedly
asked the streaming giant to remove to
remove his music the veteran rocker
fired off a public missive to his
management on monday demanding that they
remove his music from spotify in protest
of joe rogan spreading misinformation
about the kovid 19 vaccine well we have
a little update that has happened uh
just in the last little bit uh neil
young is now off spotify
it did not work out as well the spotify
people sat in a boardroom bunch of
people around the table guys neil young
joe rogan neil young joe rogan neil
young
and they went with joe rogan they went
with joe rogan and that is a great move
so i want to do a couple golf claps for
the fine folks over at spotify
they haven't made all the perfect
decisions you know the truth is that
when joe rogan moved over to spotify
they censored about 50 of his videos
they were about i think it was 46 or 48
to be precise uh videos that got taken
down from his original catalog i think
some things with uh alex jones and a
couple other people so i'm not saying
that they've been perfect on all of this
stuff but in this moment they said neil
young
you had a good run man but we're
sticking with joe rogan so so credit
where credit is due that is quite good
and now to uh shift from quite good to
quite horrible howard stern oh and this
is so depressing for me howard stern who
i grew up in new york listening to
howard stern on the fm dial when he was
edgy and irreverent and it was the
coolest freaking thing like everyone in
new york everyone in dc everyone
eventually uh countrywide as they got to
more and more stations like everyone
loved howard stern he was fighting the
power he was funny he was always
fighting with management you've probably
seen the movie private parts like the
guy was absolutely awesome
but as i tweeted out yesterday one of
the things that happens in life as you
grow up is you realize that many of your
childhood heroes become
complete maniacs because howard stern
chimed in on what spotify should do with
joe rogan then then uh you know he's not
i don't think he's for censorship i
don't think
neil young is for censorship i just
think he's saying look i don't want to
be part of this organization
because if my music is helping people
bring people to the table and then
they're spreading something as lethal as
don't take the vaccine do this
that makes you know
yeah i you know i'm against any kind of
censorship really you know i really am i
don't like censorship but when you're
talking about life and death like poor
meatloaf got sucked into some weird
[ __ ] cult
you know i used to work at siriusxm i
actually never met howard stern he had
his own wing over there but i had a show
on siriusxm on the weekends a couple
years back when i lived in new york city
before before the reuben report and it
was like my dream to meet this guy like
i have quite literally had dreams
where i meet him
and i've always wanted to do his show i
hope it happens um but this is really
disappointing this is really
disappointing first he sort of says
something that makes sense which is that
neil young is making a decision right so
that is it is neil young's choice like
and and by the way people that take a
principled approach to their life and
put their money where their mouth is i
respect that so if neil young was just
like hey i'm off this thing i don't care
about spotify it's going to cost me a
lot of money a lot of notoriety
residuals all of that stuff but i'm not
going to work with them fine neil young
sort of made an ultimatum like it's him
or me then they made a choice everyone
by the way this is what the free
market's about this is what freedom's
all about like everyone made their
choice appropriately but but what howard
stern did there that was the
disappointing part
um is where he talks about
this being lethal lethal as in don't
take the vaccine the implication being
that joe rogan
or some of his guests have said that and
that's been a reoccurring enough theme
that somehow thousands or millions of
people that are watching joe rogan are
not taking the vaccine and then dying
which of course is nonsense and of
course in america we are allowed to
debate
whether vaccines are good
whether anything is good or bad or what
it is that you are supposed to put in
your body or what it is that the
government is allowed to do when it
comes to putting those things in your
body you got it so he's sort of saying
well i'm not for censorship but i am for
censorship you see what i did there
that's basically what he's saying like
i'm not for censorship but rogan's
killing people i mean this shit's lethal
so we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to boot joe rogan it's it's so
disappointing if you know anything about
the history of howard stern and again i
would love to discuss this with you
howard if any of your people are
watching i got a book coming out in
april would be happy to come on it
doesn't have anything to do with the
book i'd be happy to come on tomorrow if
you want to make it happen uh but the
point where guys who talk for a living
like think about how many things howard
stern has said that are wildly offensive
think of some of the sex stuff think of
some of the racial jokes all that stuff
which of course i think for the most
part is funny i haven't watched howard
stern in years or listened to howard
certain years i don't know how many
people are actually listening to
siriusxm he doesn't seem to have any
real relevance anymore except when he
goes after rogan because this has
happened a few times so that that sort
of is what it is he's made choices in
his career he did the satellite radio
thing he i think he could have been a
pioneer in this right the digital world
but he chose that thing and that's
that's so be it
um
but you can't say
that you're not for censorship but this
kind of censorship because he's killing
people is okay because there's a plenty
of people out there howard stern who
would love to censor you you used to
fight those people right those are the
people you were fighting at k-rock and
some of the fm channels that you were on
right
wnbc everyone seen the movie right you
were always fighting the power because
they were censoring you related to some
of the stuff you were talking about now
it may not have been lethal stuff in
your mind but some people don't want you
to talk about sex that way some people
don't want you talking about drugs that
way or making fun of midgets or whatever
it is that you're doing you know so
slippery slope my friend but if you
think that's not sort of weird enough
right so spotify does the good thing
they keep rogan then sort of radio
legend goes after rogan well then some
more weird stuff happened this is
directly related to the united states
government we got some info here from
the daily wire u.s surgeon general vivek
murthy said tuesday on msnbc that not
only the government but big tech
companies have a role to play when it
comes to censoring so-called
misinformation and curating accurate
information to the public big tech
companies have an important role to play
since they are the predominant places
where we're seeing misinformation spread
okay so first off let's just be very
very clear about this this is as close
as you can get to an assault on the
first amendment by the government
without stepping over that line so the
uh they're allowed right the government
whether it's the president
whether it's a governor he's allowed to
express whether it's the attorney
general health secretary doesn't matter
they're allowed to express a personal
opinion sort of like oh i wish
that you know big tech companies would
do something about misinformation
because they have a right to free speech
too
but what they're doing there is
something very dangerous this idea that
you know these companies they really
should do something and we are the
governments so you know if they kind of
don't do what we like maybe we could
take a look at their books maybe we
could make sure they're not going to get
some deal that they want some
tax thing whatever it might be so this
is pretty close by the way when we talk
about
seeing misinformation
um this is the same guy who
congratulated
trans
deputy health secretary rachel levine on
being the first female
cabinet member
the first right was it the first female
cat yeah
in essence the first female cabinet
member
except she's biologically a male
you guys got all that already right like
so it's like is that misinformation she
i i do accept that she's a trans woman
meaning that she is a biological male
who is now a trans woman lives life as a
woman i accept that but that doesn't
make her female so it's like okay
misinformation like who's spreading
misinformation now if you think though
that this sort of assault on the first
amendment the idea that government
representatives would be saying oh well
you know big tech you should do this
sort of thing you guys may remember
because i have a very smart audience so
i suspect that you do
you may remember a couple months back
jen saki at one of her press briefings
basically admitting that the government
colludes with big tech to censor us take
a look in terms of actions alex that
we have taken or we're working to take i
should say from the federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for facebook that
spread this information we're working
with doctors and medical professionals
to connect uh two connected medical
experts with popular with popular who
are popular with their audiences with uh
with accurate information and boost
trusted content so we're helping get
trusted content out there we also
created the covid19 the covid community
corps to get factual information into
the hands of local messengers and we're
also investing uh as you'll have seen in
the presidents the vice presidents and
dr fauci's time
guys
guys the government just wants to get
you trusted information the government
just wants to get you factual
information and they're so good at it
and they care so much that they're going
to help big tech companies do that do
you think that maybe that could be an
infringement on free speech do you think
that maybe in these last two years where
everything they have said has turned out
to be a lie usually weeks sometimes
months later do you think that when they
mean truth do you think that when they
mean factual they just mean the [ __ ]
that they're peddling that day by the
way conor just reminded me rachel levine
was a vivec called rachel the first
female four-star general so she wasn't
the first female cabinet member
obviously first female four-star general
again she is not female i'm even using
her pronouns because i'm a nice guy
she is a male
all right you got the point so the
government now has a track record here
we have uh all sorts of people from the
government saying this is what big tech
companies should do and we know that
there i i often talk about this it's
like we know that there are connections
between big tech and the government i'm
not worried about the connections that i
know about i'm worried about the
connections that i don't know about do
they have back door access to these
things what kind of influence when
zuckerberg has a meeting with the
president like what kind of influence is
actually being applied we don't know
what's going on i mean one of the
reasons that i want to eventually make
the full move from youtube to rumble is
that we have no idea what's going on
with these algorithms and i'm not saying
that the government should come in and
fix these algorithms but for those of
you that subscribe to my videos and tell
me every single day you simply do not
see our videos in the feed it's like
well what is that
i don't know so we need better products
that's a little bit of a sidebar but a
nice segue into this final part of this
segment uh this is more from the daily
wire and this is on the bongino
censorship by youtube conservative
broadcaster and fox news host dan
bongino was permanently banned by
youtube on wednesday with the video
sharing platform claiming that he
attempted to evade a prior suspension
the ev the evasion included bongino
uploading new video content to his
primary channel while a second channel
used to share short video clips from his
radio program was actively suspended due
to code to youtube's covet 19
misinformation policy both of mongino's
youtube channels have now been shut down
and he will no longer be able to create
a new channel okay so i'm not going to
bludgeon you to death with this debate
about private
and public and you know my feelings
about whether the government should get
involved and all that stuff we can talk
about all that but this is a massive
escalation dan bongino is huge
absolutely huge millions and millions of
people listen to dan dan's buddy of mine
he's a good guy so i'm not putting that
out there like you know i have some
stake in this right like dan and i work
together at rumble so i'm being
transparent on that but dan has
tremendous influence i suspect and i
would welcome people to prove me wrong
on this that the things that he was
talking about related to covet are
actually no different than what most of
us that have been skeptical and you're
allowed to be skeptical i think in this
country still
have been saying about covert all along
i suspect that the things that youtube
suspended him for
related to covid19 misinformation would
be the exact same things that howard
stern is upset that joe rogan is saying
but joe rogan is still on youtube now
i'm not trying to give you any hints
youtube don't boot rogan but do you see
there's complete inconsistency here
there is a complete
assault on reality here and these big
tech companies
in some ways are bigger than the
government the founding fathers always
were wary of power and they thought big
government was going to be the ultimate
power but now big tech is perhaps more
powerful than big government and then
when you combine the two when you have
government people
out there literally saying we flag
things for big tech or that big tech
should censor this misinformation like
you think that's state-run media you
think that's mind control you think
that's mass formation psychosis i think
you guys get all of it so one more
commercial please do subscribe to our
rumble channel
and uh and we shall see where the future
of all of this goes let's shift to this
lady nancy pelosi you all know nancy
pelosi she is the congresswoman from up
there in northern cali san francisco
area she's worth hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars she's been in the
government for how many years i i'm
guessing it's got to be over 40 years at
this point somehow became super super
rich she served as a u.s representative
in california since 1987.
not bad nancy she's 81 years old and she
still wants to run again
she doesn't want to give up power these
people don't want to stop she could be a
scary grandmother right she wouldn't be
like a loving grandmother this is a very
scary woman you wouldn't want to see her
sort of in the morning with no makeup
grandma i want eggs
okay she put out this video
to promote her re-election and ah take a
look
hello it's nancy
thank you for the opportunity to share
some thoughts with you thank you for
giving me the privilege to represent our
city and our san francisco values in the
congress human rights reproductive
justice lgbtq equality respect for
immigrants and care for each other
when people ask me what are the three
most important issues facing the
congress i always say the same thing our
children our children our children when
you're in the arena you have to be able
to take a punch or throw a punch
for the children our democracy is at
risk because of assaults on the truth
the assault on the us capital and the
state by state assault on voting rights
this election is crucial and that is why
i am running for re-election to congress
and respectfully seek your support
hello i'm nancy pelosi
my dentures are about to fall out of my
mouth they've pulled my skin so tight
that my eyes are actually entering parts
of my forehead i am here to save your
children your children your children
your children oh i think i'm
malfunctioning your children your
children also the republicans are mean
and they don't want anyone to vote
ah what is happening to me ah i mean
that is a scary woman lady retire retire
it's time 81
you've got hundreds of millions of
dollars what is going on in your soul if
there is any soul left go
be a grandma you got all that ice cream
in your freezer remember go spend all
the money that you probably got
illegally through insider trading go do
nice things with the children go on
vacation but stop you've ruined
california you've ruined so much of this
country
i'm here for the children the children
the children
we did a little fun edit take a look
thank you for giving me the privilege to
represent our city and our san francisco
values in the congress human rights
reproductive justice lgbtq equality
respect for immigrants and care for each
other
our safe communities require gun
violence prevention addressing
the plan and supporting law enforcement
with justice and policing iron money
from re-election to congress and
respectfully seek your support
that's some fine work by connor over
there i mean the chili the children that
children that children if she really
cares about the children perhaps you'd
get critical race theory out of the
schools right perhaps you would make
sure that homeless people haven't
completely overrun san francisco it's
disgusting san francisco is disgusting
san francisco ain't the full house
exterior anymore right it ain't there
are drugs everywhere
needles
store windows broken into you all know
the story about the last time not the
last time previous second to last time
that i was in san francisco i was doing
an event with candace owens we're at
morton's steakhouse we have security in
an escalade and we're obviously on a
nice street where a morton steakhouse
would be and they broke into our car
stole my backpack some homeless guys
running around with one of my jackets
and my nintendo wii and my old notebooks
it's like it's a dump you turn that
place into a dump but we're doing it for
the
the children the children ah go away
lady
so now let's juxtapose a woman who
should go away with perhaps the type of
politician
who might be doing something good of
course in this case i'm talking about
the new governor from virginia glen
yunken who won a couple months ago it
was close
he defeated what's his name who was that
guy the crazy guy with the dancing and
it looked like he was wearing lipstick
who was the guy he used to run the
democratic uh i think he was the head of
the dnc at one time that was a nut bag
uh we'll get his name in a second god
all of these people that they seem
important that you're supposed to know
who they are and then they lose and then
you're just like oh that guy like
remember the guy who ran for vice
president with hillary clinton like tom
kane tim kaine nobody remembers these
people anymore because you shouldn't
know anything about these people terry
mcauliffe is the democrat who was a
complete lunatic who basically said you
shouldn't have any right to your
children's education what they're
learning in school
and younkin did the right thing he got
involved in the culture wars he stood up
for something and said that school
choice is important and we are not going
to allow woke-ism and critical race
theory to brainwash a generation and
everything else well that is very
upsetting to the clowns over at cnn and
here's chief
clown jim acosta uh molly um you know i
seem to remember glenn younkin
campaigning in a fleece vest
in virginia he was running as a
different kind of republican i was told
there was going to be a vest
not a soviet-style police state across
the potomac from washington
journalism
it ain't what it used to be yes okay
acosta you see what he did there now
this is a man who purports to be a
journalist right i'm an impartial
journalist i am jim acosta at cnn a
place of journalism
also describing the new governor of
virginia as uh bringing in a quote
soviet-style police state across from
the potomac by the way the woman he's
talking to this molly jong fast lady i'm
pretty sure she's called me racist on
twitter a couple times and she used to
troll me all the time i think i muted or
blocked her doesn't matter um but you
see what they do like if you're just the
average cnn person watching that and
you're just sort of blue pilled and not
really paying attention to what's going
on you'd be watching that and you'd be
going oh my oh my god
jim acosta is a bright man he's a he's a
good man and he just said that there's
some sort of soviet-style situation
happening in virginia this glen yonkin
must be a really bad dude
glenn younkin is literally forcing the
schools to give choice to the parents we
all know about everything that happened
there in lewd in virginia and all of the
stuff we all know all of the stuff
right so it's like we can either
choose what i would say are imperfect
republicans i have no doubt that i will
have disagreements with junkin and he
will most likely fail us in some ways of
course of course he will it's just how
it is
or we can choose democrats that don't
want you to have any choice in what your
children are learning and do you think
that over time
if you don't have any choice over what
your children are learning and there are
big tech companies that can force them
to see certain things and not see other
things and then there's a government
that can also influence those big tech
companies relative to what they can see
do you think you might be able to
actually change the way an entire
generation or perhaps even two
generations of people can think and do
you think maybe you could do that in
just a couple years and do you think if
you throw in a pandemic and sprinkle a
little fear on top of it do you think it
might lead to oh my god where we are
today
am i nuts
you tell me uh a couple comments from
the locals community and by the way guys
if you want to chat along with the show
and we've got a couple team members in
there during the chat uh phoenix who we
just hired he left college to take a job
with the reuben report he's in there
every day as is helen a couple comments
for you guys before we wrap up uh margot
says lizards can grow back their limbs
dave no worries i know
i know but the the leg was ripped off
and he was kind he was a little yeah you
know with the tongue like uh and the
breathing was slow so i did i took a
piece of paper from an ikea
uh instruction manual because we got a
lot of ikea stuff right here i'll never
escape the ikea bed it's just it's it's
written into my life story dave you will
always sleep on an ikea bed no matter
what so i lifted him out with the paper
i put him outside in sort of a
muddy area that i thought there's a
little water maybe he can figure it out
but i'll check after the show
i just i don't like bringing you guys
bad news i just don't think he has much
hope but if if he gets the limb back and
he's hanging around him and clyde are
chilling it'll be a great ending to the
story
zionist says the surgeon general and
anthony fauci are using the same
playbook very scary yeah you know
it really is true all of these people
all of these people they think they are
the ones who own the truth and if you
say anything counter to them that you're
being unfactual but of course these are
very same people who got everything
wrong all along right so many of these
people you know if you get the vaccine
you're not going to get coveted you're
not going to transmit covid masks work
like you know it all right you guys know
it all why has no one been fired or
really think about that more than
anything else no one really of any
influence that i know of you well we
fired nurses we fired nurses and doctors
for exercising their own medical choice
if they didn't want to get vaccinated
right but why is it that no one in
government if if if really the kovid
situation is as bad as they purport it
to be now i live in florida this is over
basically um you know you can wear
whatever you want and of course some
people are getting sick i don't mean
that there's zero covered but i mean in
terms of the the general
sort of collective in the right sense
like view of how we're going to live our
lives it's over to that degree
but but if we went from 15 days to
flatten the curve to two years later
we're still in this thing
wouldn't that mean somebody screwed up
somewhere
do you think maybe it was worthy of
somebody getting fired the janitor over
at the cdc you know the electrician over
at the nih but all of these people are
still here and there's no talk of
getting rid of anybody so no matter what
they get wrong it's not misinformation
and no matter what they get wrong they
stay so it's a pretty good gig if you
can get it i suppose
uh connor this is from helen connor is
getting a lot of applause from the
locals community for his pelosi edit
that was that was some fine work i
actually he actually did that yesterday
i was driving across the state as i said
so i did not see it until you know what
let's play it again let's bring it back
one more time nancy pelays
nancy palisi
thank you for giving me the privilege to
represent our city and our san francisco
values in the congress human rights
reproductive justice lgbtq equality
respect for immigrants and care for each
other
our safe communities require gun
violence prevention addressing
[Applause]
and respectfully seek your support
guys i'm dave rubin and thank you so
much for watching the reuben report i do
it for the children the children the
children
part two of my interview with marco
rubio who's a senator from florida
florida florida is up on youtube right
now the full thing is up ad-free at
rubidreport.logos.com
i'm fearing that my face isn't going to
go back after this goodbye i'll see you
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
you